wie funktioniert denn dieses spiel ich
hätte hier dran
herzlich willkommen hier zu einem ich
kann hinter das schild springen das ist
denn als cannabis der fahrer naja das
mitbekommen
herzlich willkommen zu einem spiel was
muss heißt das ist dein name ich bin ein
bisschen heiser weil es ist gerade
wieder acht morgens und ich muss das
video halt noch ein bisschen vor mode
zählen weil ich dachte hey wenn ich weg
bin mache ich für euch wenn ich noch ein
paar videos ron fromm starch im finish
los times getoppt und die highscore
table okay das heißt wir müssen so
schnell wie möglich irgendwie
durchlaufen können doppelsprünge machen
und können das ganze ding halt allgemein
mit den pfeiltasten steuern was soll ich
jetzt man okay das kann man den teil was
ich sollte vielleicht nicht so viel
scheiße wieder labor
ich hoffe das geht klar dass ich so ein
bisschen heiser windows ist das sondern
hinter prüfen jetzt ohne spaß hatte ich
habe ein taktik wie soll das denn gehen
hier vielleicht muss irgendwie da rein
auf den knopf glaube ich hatte
vielleicht ein ganz viel fantasie ganz
viel zeit lassen
juni gewonnen hatte ich kann mir hier
drauf
was ist das denn hier was muss den
himmel wie so blockiert mich dass das
kann ich dann kann ich ihnen ja
irgendwas machen
oh oh oh so dass natürlich bis pop
so schafft jetzt euro was mach ich den
tisch bevor du hast dich so ist ganz
easy was wie denn das nicht doch da
einfach lange wie kein sinn hier wie
soll ich denn da hoch nämlich verarschen
ich krieg die krise jedoch was ist denn
daran so schwer macht doch einfach daran
wie soll ich denn da
ok weiter geht's keine möglichkeit
vortäuschen fasten lautet das kann nicht
das ist nicht so schwer das muss doch
was ganz easy es einfach sein das kann
doch nicht sein dass ich wieder hier
ich wollte einfach die ukulele spieler
werden das ist einfach so einfach für
mich nicht bestimmt worden sollte ich
muss jedoch einfach nur wie ist es denn
möglich darf so hoch zu kommen
wie funktioniert denn dieses spiel ich
hätte hier dran
es ist nicht möglich
wer macht so ein spiel ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht ob es einfach daran liegt
dass ich müde bin dass ich hier nichts
kind kriege warte ich las man den knopf
los das wäre vielleicht eine möglichkeit
ja ja denn skills hätte wohl nur aus wo
ich denke ich war so ich hab's zu
verstand war luca die teile pushen die
ich hoch und das helikopter sondern ein
ventilator ja ich weiß aber ich komme ja
trotzdem ich darüber gehört auch hier
erste geht noch klappen und dann jetzt
hier
da wie soll das gehen ich hab da hatte
ich keine nerven dafür jetzt einfach
hierhin nein ich muss nicht mehr